I am putting in Castro on my breast to where it has been the only thing that has stopped the bleeding.
So this goes back to that other question about Castro on their
tumor. But now there's a lot of white blotches and lines that look like fungus.
What do you suggest that I do to deal with the white fungus coming out of the tumor if anything?
So if there's stuff coming out of the tumor, maybe that's almost always a good thing.
If it's a fungus, you can certainly put some hydrogen peroxide in a bottle
and squirt a little bit of that on the open wound. You can use some colloidal silver
in a bottle and squirt a little bit of that. You know, treat that a couple times a day
and an alternate, maybe those two. I would do those two things.
I don't think the Castro is either fungus, but it may be dried out. So those two
suggestions might help kill it if it is.